>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Betsy Peterson: Betsy
Peterson, the Director
of the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress.
And on behalf of the staff, and
indeed everyone at the library,
I want to welcome
everyone here today
for the latest presentation
in our Benjamin Botkin
lecture series.
For those of you the
Botkin series allows us
to highlight the leading --
the work of leading scholars
in the disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, world history,
and cultural heritage, while
enhancing our collections
at the American Folklife Center.
For the center and the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisition activity.
Each lecture is videotaped,
and becomes part
of the permanent
collections of the center.
And eventually are webcast
on the library's website
where they're available
for viewing internet
patrons throughout the world,
and for generations to come.
So, today's lecture.
Today's lecture is a two-for
great pleasure for me.
I have the honor of introducing
our speaker, Peggy Bulger,
who is a distinguished
folklorist, a very dear friend
and colleague, and my
predecessor here as Director
of the American Folklore Center
at the Library of Congress.
She in turn, will be speaking
about a remarkable man
named Stetson Kennedy
who for many years was also
closely alive with the center --
or, actually, yeah, the center,
the archive, the library,
and the field of folklore.
But, first a little
bit about Peggy.
>> Peggy Bulger:
Don't tell it all.
>> Betsy Peterson: I
won't, don't worry.
Dr. Bulger received
her MA in Folk Studies
from Western Kentucky
University,
and her PhD in Folklore and
Folklife from the University
of Pennsylvania in 1992.
She began her professional
career in Florida serving
as Florida's State Folk
Arts Coordinator in 1975,
and later as the administrator
of the Florida Folklife
Program from 1976 to 1989.
As Florida's first
State Folklorist,
she was the driving
force behind the creation
of the Folklife program there,
and the Florida Folklife
collection.
Which today is housed
in Tallahassee
at the state archives
of Florida,
and features documentation
on Florida folk artists,
performers, and folklorists.
After helping to establish
the Florida Folklife program,
Peggy moved on to
Atlanta leaving Florida,
and became the Folk
Arts Director
and Senior Program Officer for
the Southern Arts Federation.
After an innovative tenure
in that position in 1991,
she was named Director
of the Library
of Congress's American
Folklife Center where she served
with distinction as AFC Director
until her retirement in 2011.
In addition to this
varied career
and her administration work,
Peggy has also authored
or coauthored numerous articles
and publications including,
South Florida Folklife and
Musical Roots of the South.
She's produced several
documentary films including
Music Masters and Rhythm Kings.
And she coproduced the double
album Drop on Down in Florida,
which was reissued on
Dust to Digital in 2012.
She also served as President of
the American Folklore Society,
and received an honorary
doctorate
from Goucher College in 2012.
After retiring, Peggy
returned to Florida
where she's remained
extremely active,
which wouldn't be a surprise
for anyone who knows her.
And in fact, she
joins us today to talk
about her most recent project,
a biography of the
folklorist Stetson Kennedy.
As you are going to hear,
Stetson Kennedy has also
lead a remarkable life
as a political activist,
writer, and folklorist.
He was a longtime friend
and supporter of the AFC,
and he maintained an
influential circle
of friends throughout his
life including, Pete Seeger,
Woody Guthrie, Alan
Lomax, Richard Wright,
Jean-Paul Sartre, Zora Neal
Hurston, and also used folklore
and oral history as a vehicle
towards progressive change.
Copies of Dr. Bulger's
book, right here,
are on sale in the
foyer after the lecture.
And Peggy will be available
to autograph copies
immediately after her talk.
So, now, please join me in
welcoming Dr. Peggy Bulge
for her talk on Stetson
Kennedy; Applied Folklore
and Cultural Advocacy.
[ Applause ]
>> Peggy Bulger: Thank you.
Well, it's really wonderful to
be back here at the library.
And I want to especially
the American Folklife Center
and staff, you know, Betsy,
thank you very much for that.
Nancy Gross, Thea Austin,
Jennifer Cudding, all of you,
Steve Winnick, all of you
have put a lot of work.
I know how much work goes into
these things, because we used
to put them on when I was here.
So, I'm happy to be on the
other side of the lectern,
and I telling somebody when
I was getting ready for this,
I said, you know, I
really need a staff.
I had to learn how to do
a Power Point on my own
for the first time, that's the
downside of retirement, but,
now I'm up and running.
Let me just take this,
and page up and page down.
See, I'm getting really
good at this here,
page up and page down.
This lecture though, is really
meant to introduce you all
to a most amazing
activist as Betsy had said,
and an extraordinary,
ordinary man
who many people have never
heard of outside of Florida.
I imagine, maybe all of you did,
does anybody not have
heard about Stetson?
Oh, good. Oh, good.
Well, you are going
to be amazed.
All of you are going to be
amazed actually, because even
if you know Stetson, or
think you know about Stetson,
if you delve into his life
it's much more amazing
than even you know.
But, so to begin, I really have
to talk about how I met Stetson,
and that was back in 1976.
As Betsy said, I was hired --
my very first job as a
folklorist was to come down
and be the State Folk Arts
Coordinator for a year on one
of those NEA one-year
grants, you know,
to do a folk arts survey
of the state in 12 months.
And I was young and often naive
enough to think it was possible.
Yes, I'm going to
-- I'd never been
to Florida before in my life.
So, the good thing is, I
decided I'd better find
out who had done any work
in Florida before me.
And so, I went to the University
of Florida Library collection,
and met up with Dr.
Alton Morris,
who at the time was the
Editor of Southern Folklore.
And he was also the Senior
Folklorist really working
in the state of Florida.
And I was going through a
lot of the WPA materials,
the Federal Writers
Project materials that were
at the P.K. Yonge Collection.
And, you know, reading Zora
Neal Hurston, Alan Lomax,
Herbert Halpert,
all kinds of people
who had been doing wonderful
work all over the state.
But, I kept running across
the names Stetson Kennedy,
I'd never heard of
Stetson Kennedy.
And so, I was talking to
Dr. Morris and I said, gosh,
you know, this guy Stetson
Kennedy did so much work,
it's really too bad he's dead.
And Morris goes, "Stetson?
He's not dead, he's
alive and well,
and lives outside
of Jacksonville."
And of course, I was 25 years
old, and I figured anybody
who had been doing
that work in the 1930s,
this was 1976 had to
be dead, you know?
So -- and I'm embarrassed
to say,
he was only 62 years
old in 1976.
Whoo! You know, older
than I am now [inaudible].
Anyway, so, that started,
I made an appointment to go
over to see Stetson on his land.
He had an estate I would
say, south of Jacksonville
in St. Johns County called
Beluthahatchee, which is word
that he got from
Zora Neal Hurston,
which kind of means
a paradise on earth,
at least that's what
he tells me.
So, I went over to
interview him about his work
with the Federals
Writer Project,
because that's all
I knew about him.
And that actually began
a friendship that lasted
over 35 years until he died.
But his work with the Florida
Writers Project was just the tip
of the iceberg in an amazing
life that really used his skills
as a documentarian
to affect political,
environmental, and
cultural change.
Stetson Kennedy was actually,
he was born on October 5,
1916 to George Kennedy and
Willie Stetson in Riverside,
which is a wealthy
neighborhood in Jacksonville,
Florida, it still is today.
He is descendent
from southern Georgia
and Florida aristocracies,
so the surnames
in his family are
Woodward, Sanford, Lanier,
Wallace, Stetson, and Kennedy.
His most celebrated relative was
his great uncle John B. Stetson,
as many of you might
have heard of him.
He was a northern hat
manufacturer who moved actually
to Deland, Florida in the 1880s
And founded the first law school
in the state, Stetson
University.
So, Stetson was the eldest
of five children who grew
up with all of the rights,
privileges and prejudices
of their station in life.
And so, from right to left
that's Stetson, the oldest,
Martha, George Junior,
Nancy, and Margaret.
And Stetson said to me that
the, "He grew up steeped
in southern culture
of the 1920s.
Salt and pepper were
the only condiments,
and garlic was frowned
upon as not only alien,
but positively subversive."
Stetson as a teenager would help
in his father's retail furniture
business in Jacksonville,
which catered to poor
and working-class customers
both Black and White.
And they would pay a dollar
down and a dollar a week
for all of their purchases.
And it was Stetson's job to
go collect that dollar a week.
So, it was at that early
age, you know, at about 15,
that he first began to document
the speech, idioms, jokes,
and stories of those families.
It was also the beginning
of his interest in folklore
and in activism to help
combat poverty and hunger.
Stetson was always considered
to be the black sheep
of his family.
His interest in Black culture,
traditions of the working class,
and in the inequality of
southern life was not welcomed
within his family
as you can imagine,
and also within his
"social peers."
He began college at the
University of Florida in 1935,
which was the height
of The Depression.
He was studying literature and
writing, he was also active
in social causes though
right from the beginning.
He joined the North
American Committee
to aid Spanish democracy.
And he had the University
of Florida ROTC members
send their used boots
to the Spanish Republican
troops.
And he mobilized the cigar
rollers of Tampa in Key West
by appealing to their
Spanish heritage.
He also -- this is
really interesting,
he founded the Florida
International Peace Council,
which was the very first
integrated student group
in the segregated South.
Their slogan was, and this
was before World War II,
"Keep America out of the war by
keeping war out of the world."
But, as Stetson says, he
invented independent studies
by dropping out of college
in 1937, and hitchhiking
to Key West where he intended
to collect narratives,
and become a working
writer for a year or two.
So, remember, this is at the
height of The Depression.
Key West was actually
under federal jurisdiction,
and it was an experiment
to use WPA labor
to create a tourist mecca
and save the bankrupt
town in this effort.
It was also the beginning
of what would evolve
into the Civilian Conservation
Corp. The WPA workers were
taking houses like this, and
restoring them into this.
The WPA was creating jobs
to develop roads, bridges,
and critical infrastructure.
As well as jobs that would
encourage economic development
through tourism.
So, when Stetson first arrived,
he got a WPA job raking
seaweed off the beaches
to attract these elusive
tourists, one of the many jobs
that got people to work.
And he immediately
started collecting folklore
from his fellow workers
who were also destitute
and grateful for the job.
So, one story he told me --
and he said it was
great to have this job,
because the sea was
very obliging
by depositing another crop
of seaweed every day, and so,
there was never an
end to the job.
But he said, "These fellas
on the beach, one fellow took
out a loaf of Cuban
bread, slices it,
holds it up to the breeze,
and then he takes it down.
He cuts a lime, he squeezes
the lime juice on the bread,
puts it together and eats it.
So, all the other
workers are asking,
"What the hell he's
-- was he doing?"
And he said, Well, I just
made a sea breeze sandwich.
So, I guess he was getting
a little fishy flavor
and imagining that he
had a fish sandwich.
But there was that kind
of good humor in the face
of the awful economic
situation."
Stetson began to document the
traditional occupational lure
of Key Westers.
He went down on the wharfs,
he went on the sponge boats
and the docks, and he collected
from the Bohemian conch
fisherman of the day.
Because of this, he
came to the attention --
I love this picture, she --
doesn't even look like--
I know, what a babe.
And she was the head
of the Florida --
Florida Writers Project.
Anyway, he came to the
attention of Dr. Carita Corse,
who was a family friend from
Jacksonville, and the new head
of the Florida Writers Project.
She hired Stetson
at the age of 21
to be a Junior Interviewer
covering Key West.
And that was because of
his family connections.
The project was gathering
material, as most of you know,
to publish a state guide book.
And most of the states,
of course, were engaged
in similar field work for a
series that would be published
and encourage visitation
across the country.
It was kind of an
economic development thing
through writing.
Stetson submitted manuscripts
were full of folklore
and cultural narratives.
And he then came to the
attention of who else?
Dr. Benjamin Botkin, who this
lecture series is named for.
Botkin was the head of the
Federal Writers Project Folklore
and Oral History Unit
in Washington D.C.
overseeing all of the states.
And Botkin encouraged Corse to
hire Stetson to be in charge
of the "Folklore Oral History
and Social Ethnic Unit"
of the Florida team.
And so, at the age of 22,
Stetson became a
Federal Folklorist.
Stetson was able to borrow the
acetate disk recording machine
of the Library of Congress's
Archive of Folk Song,
and I believe we still
have that machine here.
Yeah, we do.
And along with photographer
Robert Cook,
they documented the folk
arts and culture of Key West.
And here, he is documenting
Edith Ogden,
who became his first wife.
Stetson had seven wives,
but that's another story.
And she's singing a Cuban
folk song for the project.
And after the talk, you should
go see some of the materials
that Todd Harvey and
staff have pulled.
Stetson's materials that are
here, right here in our archive.
These are all coming from
interviews that I did
with him over, I don't know,
200 hours of interviews
over maybe 15 years.
He said, "I lived in
the Cuban Quarter,
and it was my first exposure to
any culture other than the Black
and Cracker southern cultures.
So, to find myself in a Cuban,
Spanish speaking community
was quite an eye-opener.
In spite of all the hardships,
they were having a ball.
They were really enjoying life
in a way I'd never seen
anybody enjoying life.
It had something to do with
the Creole outlook on life,
making the most of it.
Wine, women, and song,
and making music.
You can't beat it,
it was all new to me,
and I've never gotten over it.
I probably never
should have left.
So, Stetson really was,
you know, you imagine,
22 years old, he's excited.
He did so much documentation
down there,
this is documentation
Cuban Comparsas dancers.
He documented second line
funeral parades in Key West.
And of course, Bohemian
Goombay and Junkanoo Festivals.
He also was sent on field trips
by Carita Corse to
other communities.
And this is from a trip he made
to Tarpon Springs where many
of you might know that
60% of the population
of Tarpon Springs
were immigrants
from the Dodecanese Islands.
They were brought over to
get the natural sponges
out of the bay, and they
were really very good
at that occupation.
But, to this day,
the Greek culture
of Tarpon is a tourist
draw, and so, it, you know,
could be a dream come true,
I guess for at the time.
Stetson also documented the
cigar rollers in both Key West
and Tampa for occupational lure,
as well as political
activism pertaining
to the Batista Regime in Cuba.
And I should say that, the Cigar
rollers were really interesting
in that, they started --
you know, the Cuban cigar
rollers first came to Key West,
and when they wanted
to unionize,
the owners of the cigar
companies moved lock, stock,
and barrel up to Tampa to
Ybor City to avoid unionizing.
And one of the jobs
though in these factories,
which you can see they're
all just working away mind --
it's pretty mindless
work after a while,
was to be electore[Phonetic].
If you were a electore, you were
a man who sat up on a high -
high stool, and you
read to the workers.
So, it's like books on
tape before books on tape.
And you could read anything
that the workers wanted.
And what they increasingly
wanted read were the political
newspapers of the day,
and activist materials.
And so, it was a sad
day, but eventually,
the cigar rolling companies
got rid of that job,
and tore down electores
high seats.
And that was -- the was cause
for a great consternation
within the industry there.
But, Stetson also documented
cigar rollers' houses vernacular
architecture in Key West,
shot gun houses like this.
And typical street scenes
in his Cuban neighborhood.
This give me -- you can see
that they had Turtle burgers,
turtle burger sandwich
at the time, you know,
which sea turtles
are endangered now,
so you wouldn't get a
turtle burger sandwich.
But, I wonder what that
tasted like, well --
he also documented
cock fighting,
which at the time was not
illegal down in Key West.
And he became great friends
with an emerging young
Cuban-American folk artist,
Mario Sanchez.
Sanchez's work is not
internationally collected,
but back in the 1930s, he
was a young, unknown artist.
And the Florida Writers
Project documentation would help
to start his career.
He would do bas-relief paintings
on cibar -- cigar box covers,
and other found wood pieces.
And they celebrated
the traditional,
everyday life of Key West.
This one is called Gossip, this
one is called Street Vendors.
But, I want you to see he --
during the middle of his career,
he got really into the clouds.
And the clouds are telling
all kinds of stories,
there's bull fighting, and
there's you know, fishing.
And so, the clouds are
just as interesting
as what's going on
in the street.
This one is called Pets.
And this is simply called a
street scene, because it's got
so much detail, and it
gives you a good inkling
of what Key West must have
been like in the 1930s.
Of course, Stetson was now in
charge of the folklore unit
and the folklore connection
all over the state.
So, Cartia Corse called
him back to Jacksonville
to supervise the field
workers from the main office.
He was soon to become
the supervisor
of Zora Neal Hurston,
if that's possible.
He -- she was moving back down
to Florida from New York City
where she had been with the
brilliant anthropologist
Franz Boaz.
She was also a Pulitzer Prize
winning author at the time.
And Stetson remembers the
day that she was hired.
He says, "When it was
announced that Zora was coming
into the Jacksonville
headquarters,
Dr. Corse called a meeting
of the Editorial staff.
She said that we would have
to make allowances for Zora,
because she had been lionized
by New York literary circles,
and was consequently
given to putting on airs.
She would, for instance,
smoke cigarettes
in front of White people."
So, I asked Stetson,
what happened?
"So, Zora came, Zora smoked,
and we made allowances.
Although she was an
award-winning published author,
Zora was hired at the minim wage
for the WPA, $26.50 a month,
as a junior interviewer
to collect Negro Folklore
with the Negro Unit.
Of course, as you know,
in the South the WPA,
the Federal Writers
Project units were separated
by race at the time.
She did amazing work, and sent
in important documentation
of everything from the
juke joints of Eatonville,
to the railroad workers
from the state prison yards,
to Blues musicians in Pahokee,
and to turpentine
workers at Chipley.
And I'm very happy to say that
if you want to hear and see,
and get into some of these
materials, it's all digitized.
It's up online, and it's here
at the American Folklife Center.
So, get into the website, and
get into collections online,
and it's the Florida collection.
But, it was also during
this time that Stetson met
and became friends with
Pete Seeger, as well as many
of the other Folk Song
Revival members from the North.
And remember, this was the era
where Pete Seeger
was the first archive
of folksong's first intern.
And he was working
with Alan Lomax.
Alan Lomax, of course, was
the head of the archive
of folk songs at the
Library of Congress.
And he would come down to
Florida to do field work
with Stetson, Zora Neal
Hurston, Herbert Halpert,
and other prominent folklorists.
And he and Stetson maintained
a friendship throughout
their lives.
So, at the end of the 1930s,
and the beginning of the 1940s,
Stetson became involved
-- before the WPA had --
you know, wound up,
he became involved
in the early civil
rights struggles
and labor struggles
of the South.
He joined the Southern
Conference for Human Welfare.
He met and worked with
other Progressive reformers,
Josephine Wilkins,
Claude Pepper, W.T. Couch.
Ellis Arnall, George
Stoney, Clark Foreman,
Don West, and Virginia Durr.
He would also meet and work
with Miles and Ziphia Horton
of the Highlander
Center in Tennessee.
And this is Ziphia, and
she is actually credited
with being the first person
to use a traditional
African-American hymn as a tool
for activism at this
time, and of course,
it's We Shall Overcome.
Many of you know it, because a
young folk singer Guy Carawan
was working with Highlander
-- at the center at the time.
And he actually, was doing
a lot of the song leading
at song rallies and gatherings.
Stetson would note that this was
one of the most effective ways
to use folklore for
positive change.
Traditional tunes would be
joined by progressive lyrics
to bring people to their
feet and move them in ways
that speeches alone could not.
And I was privileged to
interview Miles Horton
on December 5, 1989 three
weeks before he died.
And he explained to me why he
used Stetson as a consultant.
So, Miles Horton said, "At
Highlander, we used a lot
of consultants, Stetson was
working on books, and so,
he came to meet people,
and to talk the students.
We were always happy
to have him around.
It was good for the students
to know people like that.
He had a broader base
than most folklorists.
Most of the folklorists
don't get political,
they're afraid they'd
be called Communists,
and have their book
sales go down.
But, he, Stetson, was
very open about it.
Stetson, he was a philosopher,
he was totally interested
in the significance of folklore.
When he put folklore
in his books,
it was for its significance,
not just as a fact.
It's only the folklorists
like Stetson
that I like to work with.
I don't have any patience
for the fact collectors.
I find them exceedingly boring."
There you go.
By this time -- no, in 1942
the WPA programs as many
of you know, were shut down
very abruptly due to the entry
of the U.S. into World War II.
But, by this time,
Stetson had taken much
of the state guide book
material that he had collected,
that was not going to be used
in the official tourism tool,
and he wrote his
first successful book,
Palmetto Country,
and there's a copy
of it back there on the table.
Which depicted Florida
not just in all
of its good characteristics,
but also all
of its bad qualities too.
And then, he tried
to join the Army.
He was rejected from joining the
Army because of a back injury,
so he determined to
fight Fascism at home.
For the next five years,
Stetson lived a double life.
He moved to Atlanta,
under the name
of John Perkins he infiltrated
the Stone Mountain klavern
of the Klu Klux Klan.
He was determined to document
secretly the Klan's own
folklore, and use this to expose
their unlawful activities,
and also their tools
for communication
that would be less
affective without secrecy.
So, this following section
I'm going to be talking about,
which is his work, and
how he used folklore
to get the charter revoked
in the Georgia Klan.
It was written back in 1992
when the dissertation came out,
and it held true then.
Unfortunately, recent events
may put this commentary
into question again, because
without overwhelming public
outrage and sanction against
blatant racism and abuse
of human rights, the tactics
that Stetson Kennedy used would
have been minimally affective.
Fortunately, they were
very affective at the time.
Kennedy knew that naming is
power, exposing the secret names
and signs of the Klan would
steal the symbolic heart
from the organization,
and make them vulnerable.
He determined to
sap their strenght
by turning their own
rituals against them,
by revealing their
cherished passwords,
and destroying their
exclusive brotherhood.
By exposing this elaborately
constructed folk society,
and its destructive ideology,
the cultural glue melts,
and by holding those in power
accountable without the cloak
of secrecy and mysticism,
the society breaks apart.
This then was the methodology
adopted by Stetson Kennedy
and his role as an
implied folklorist.
And I just have to say,
I love this picture,
it's Klansmen with Kewpie dolls.
It's I think at a country fair,
and I'm just like going --
oh, it was so ubiquitous
that you know, this was --
this would not like, stop
people in their tracks,
I guess, I can't imagine.
In all, Stetson as John Perkins
joined over 20 hate groups
in Georgia where he
-- and this is him
in his Columbian Brown shirt.
The Columbians were a rival hate
group competing with the Klan.
But, all of them were
dependent upon secrecy,
and bogus traditions.
This is a map of the Klavern,
and he did give information
that showed all of the positions
of power, and their place
in the clubhouse, and
what they were used for,
and what the crazy naming meant.
This is a secret salute.
He did a bunch of documentation
of hand gestures,
and what they meant.
So, if you met -- for instance,
if a Klansman met another
Klansman on the street,
they could make these
hand signals,
and the other person would know
what they're talking about.
If they weren't a Klansman,
I guess they'd just think
you're crazy, I don't know.
And Stetson also would collect
handouts and wires as much
as he could while
he was undercover.
During 1946 and 1947, Stetson
fed nationally famous journalist
Drew Pearson the secret minutes
of the Stone Mountain
Klan meetings.
Pearson would announce
these secrets
on his Sunday night radio
show, the Merry-Go-Round.
Stetson also gave this
information to Robert Maxwell,
the producer of the
Superman radio show.
And he was working
undercover for Daniel Duke,
the Attorney General
for Georgia,
and the Georgia Bureau
of Investigation.
But, he knew it was time to
come out from under cover
and bring his information to
Capitol Hill in January of 1947.
In his full regalia, he entered
the office, believe it or not
of Martin Dies, and the House on
American Activities Committee.
Dies refused to see Stetson,
and maintained the Klan
was not un-American,
it was as American as apple pie.
Of course, showing up
announced to the Capitol
in a Klan robe had
some consequences,
and Stetson though
was able to testify
to several Congress members,
and many members of the press.
Of course, this blew his cover,
and his life would be in danger.
Meanwhile, Georgia Attorney
General Dan Duke would use
evidence from Stetson's work
to confront the former governor
of Georgia, Eugene Talmadge,
who was a Klan member himself
with the whips that were
used in several hate crimes
against Blacks in Atlanta.
And really, it -- the
Klan was a huge --
huge factor in American
life back at this time.
This is Stetson with
Ellis Arnall
who was the progressive governor
who succeeded Eugene Talmadge.
And with Stetson's
evidence, Arnall was able
to get the Georgia Klan's
charter revoked, and --
because they were
chartered as an educational,
charitable organization.
And they had enough
evidence to show
that the Klan was
actually conspiring
to deny people their
civil rights.
But, this of course, made things
very difficult for Stetson.
His land in Florida
was set on fire,
and his house was
ransacked by local Klansman.
He was getting death
threats every day,
so he was weighing
his options let's say.
He decided to go visit
his friend Alan Lomax
in New York city who was working
with the Henry Wallace campaign.
And it was at a party at Lomax's
apartment finally met somebody
he'd been corresponding with for
over three years, Woody Guthrie.
They had amazing
correspondence going on,
but this is how it started.
Kennedy's first contacts
with Woody were by mail.
In April of 1945, Wood wrote to
Stetson concerning an article
that Stetson had written
for Southern Patriot,
about the racist group
called Christian Americans.
Woody had been so
impressed with the article
that he sent Stetson
a book of 10 songs.
And Stetson had answered him
detailing how he himself was a
collector of folk songs.
So, Wood replied with a
two-page, single spaced letter
that would begin
a long friendship
between the two activists.
And the end of that
letter it says,
"Your Southern Patriot
is doing a fine job
of making it clear how the
Fascists will try every known
trick in their booby-trap
to plant their seeds
in the soils of our Southland.
It is the ignorance
caused by poverty
that keeps Fascism alive.
And you're in the big middle
of the land where the light
of prosperity has never
shined for a whole day.
Your friend, Woody Guthrie."
So, Woody had also
written to Stetson
after he had read
Palmetto Country.
And that of course, was
a book that got Stetson
on the map in many ways.
So, he wrote to him --
About Palmetto Country.
"Dear Stets, I don't know of
a book on my whole shelf Stet,
that hits me harder than
your Palmetto Country.
I've read it, and I'm still
reading it, and I can now say
that if only, and if only all
our library books could say what
you did, the jokes, the songs,
the old ballads about the Voodoo
and the Hoodoo and
the Bigley winds
down in your neck
of the wood vine.
If every book on the
shelf hit, and kicked,
and jumped in just the right
direction just 2/3 as much
as your Palmetto Country does,
I'd feel much more like a man.
Most damn books make me
feel like an asshole.
But -- but if -- and
that's spelled A-S-S,
new word, W-H-O-L-E.
But a few like yours
have kept me standing
up like a Saw Leaf palm.
I'm going to go down
some day and try a piece
of that sweet Palmetto Country.
Keep on traveling where your
own free conscious takes you --
as you always do anyway.
And there's no earthly
ends to the goods
and benefits you can perform.
Your Stud Buddie,
Woody Guthrie."
See, he was amazing.
Woody and Stetson began -- of
course, became fast friends.
And In 1951, Woody
would come to stay
with Stetson at Beluthahatchee.
He had -- by this
time, he had devised --
divorced his wife Marjorie,
and he was showing signs
of what we now know
was Huntington's Korea,
but he was just as prolific
and creative as ever.
While staying at Beluthahatchee,
he would write several songs
for Stetson's campaign, and
this picture is actually Woody
at Beluthahatchee.
So, he was writing songs
for Stetson's campaigns.
Stetson was running for
Florida State Senate
as a Color-Blind
Write-in candidate.
He didn't win.
He was running against George
Smathers, who was a proud member
of what was known as the
Porkchop Gang, and if you're
from Florida, or know Florida,
the Porkchop Gang is
incredibly infamous.
And Smathers was a demagogue
who used language and innuendo
to exploit the intolerances
of his audiences,
what we might call his base.
One of Smather's speeches
against Stetson's good friend,
the progressive candidate
Claude Pepper,
is a master piece of
cultural sabotage.
And this is an actual quote
that was used by Smathers.
And I've seen it
in other places,
but Stetson had told
me about it.
He said about Claude Pepper,
and this is to a
rally that he was at.
"Are you aware that
Claude Pepper is known all
over Washington as a
shameless extrovert?
Not only that, but this
man is reliably reported
to practice nepotism
with his sister-in-law.
And he has a sister who was once
a Thespian in wicked New York.
Worst of all, it is
an established fact
that Mr. Pepper, before his
marriage practiced celibacy."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. You know, some things
never change, I just -- anyway.
That was George Smathers.
You know, if you don't
know Florida politics,
you really should read up on it,
because it's quite interesting.
So, interestingly, one
of Woody's campaign songs
that he wrote titled Stetson
Kennedy, would be recorded
in 2000 by Billy
Bragg and Wilco.
And it's on, I think,
Mermaid Avenue number II.
So, if you have that
CD or anything, go back
and listen to Stetson Kennedy.
Another one of the songs
is Kennedy, he's that man,
I'll just read a
little chorus of it.
As I say, these songs
were great,
they didn't swing the
election, but they were great.
This -- Kennedy, He's That Man.
"Stetson Kennedy, he's that man,
walks and talks across our land.
Talking out against the Ku Klux
Klan, for every fiery cross
and note, I'll get
Kennedy 100 votes.
And I'll walk him to his
office on that morning, yes,
I'll walk him -- meet him
in his office on that day.
I'll write Kennedy
in that square box
on the sweet election morn,
and I'll writer old Smathers
Dupont down the drain.
I'll melt all your guns and
tanks into homes for every Yank.
Stetson Kennedy knows my
troubles, he's that man.
Stetson Kennedy, he's that
man, he knows my hopes
and prayers and plans.
Knows I need a job of work for
life from cradle to my grave.
From Key West, north
to Jacksonville.
Stetson Kennedy fills my bill,
and I'll walk him to his office
on the morning, yes, I'll take
him to his office on that day."
Woody Guthrie actually
would come back to stay
at Beluthahatchee in 1952,
where he would write
a total of 88 songs.
And he -- and at the same time,
he finished his manuscript
for Seeds of Man
while he was there.
So, Beluthahatchee was
designated a Florida landmark
in 2003 by The Friends
of Libraries USA due
to Woody's creativity
while he was in Florida.
Woody had an a -- now, you have
to understand, Stetson was not
on his land at that time, I'll
tell you about where he was.
So, Woody and his girlfriend
at the time, his companion
at the time, Andike[Phonetic]
had come to Beluthahatchee,
they were living in the woods.
It was very scandalous, because
apparently, they were taken
to going naked a
lot of the times.
But, he had an accident with
lighter fluid when he was there,
and his -- there was
-- this was great.
I found -- this is the
file on record when he went
to the emergency room.
They had a little fire,
you know, when you go in
and they have to take
information from you,
and they never show
you what's on file.
This was it, "Patent says he
plays stringed instruments.
The patient is a peculiar, he
wears shaggy hair and beard,
which he says is to
keep the mosquitos away.
This couple are drifters, came
down here several months ago.
Patient is supposed to be
a musician, folk music.
He has quite a history."
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, Woody was
down there, and as I said,
Stetson was not there,
he was in Europe.
In 1952, the UNESCO Conference
of the U.S. National Commission
was meeting in Paris and Geneva.
And there was an
ad hoc committee
that would hear evidence
on forced labor
and slavery across the world.
Stetson had heard that they had
concluded there was no forced
labor in the United States.
He contacted the
committee to insist
that he had irrefutable evidence
of forced labor in Florida.
He was referring to the
recordings that he had done
as a folklorist
in the Turpentine camps
of the Pan Handle.
With testimony by poor
Black workers who were kept
in virtual slavery by being
quartered out in the pinewoods
under the eye of
a White overseer.
And they were paid in script,
which meant they could
only spend their money
at the company store, which was
also in the middle of the woods.
And they were forever in
debt, and those who tried
to run away were
murdered if caught.
And Stetson, actually, this
is an aside, he would tell me
about when they were
doing this recording,
he had gotten permission to
bring the big recording machine
into the woods by saying he
was collecting folk songs.
And so, as long as the
overseer was around,
they would be collecting
folk songs.
And when the overseer went away,
he started collecting
stories about the life.
And he had a lookout there,
and -- who would say, "Quick!
The man coming, sing a song!"
And so, they'd go
back to singing songs.
But, he collect -- collected
quite an amazing amount
of material.
Similar conditions were found
in the migrant labor camps
of South Florida's
vegetable farms.
And so, on November 5, 1952,
Stetson Kennedy boarded a plane
for Geneva to present
this evidence
to the UNESCO Committee.
He had a one-way ticket and
seven dollars to his name,
and he wouldn't return
for eight years.
After the UNESCO conference
where he did give testimony,
Stetson went behind the
Iron Curtain illegally,
and this is a funny story.
He -- back at that time,
he was in West Berlin,
and he got on the subway.
And when you hit the end of
West Berlin and you're going
into East Berlin, at the time,
they would just tell you,
if you don't have papers
to go into East Berlin,
you've got to get off
the subway now, well,
he just didn't get off.
And so, he comes
up in East Berlin,
and that's another whole
story for another whole day,
but it's in the book,
and what happened
to him behind the Iron Curtain.
But, he was hoping to find
that Communism was a system
of equality and fairness.
At this time, of course,
everybody was really looking
for answers any way they could.
And he was crushed to
find that the Roma people,
the Gypsies of the Soviet
Union were just as oppressed
as the Blacks of
the American South.
So, Communism was not
the answer either.
So, Stetson escaped the Soviet
Union, believe it or not.
He was in Hungary and Budapest
during the Hungarian Revolution
of 1956.
And he escaped back to Paris
where he was basically put
under house arrest by
the Paris Jean d'armes,
because he was a person
without a valid passport.
So, he would be let go during
the day to have a 24-hour pass,
but he had to check himself
back into jail at night.
It worked out well for
him, actually, he was --
he got three squares
a day, yeah.
It was at this time that
Stetson met and became friends
with a large community
of American ex-patriots,
including Richard
Wright, who was trying
to get him a new passport.
But, as you can imagine,
the House on American Activities
Committee did not look favorably
on a man who had been
writing for the Soviet TASS.
Finally, it was Jean Paul
Sartre who pulled strings
and got Stetson a passport to
return home in February of 1960.
Now, when he was overseas,
he was not just lying around.
While in Europe, Stetson
had been published
in 20 different languages.
And so, these are just
some of the book covers --
books that he was
writing when he was there.
And when he came back, he
again stared his civil rights
and labor advocacy immediately.
And this is a letter he
received from Martin Luther King
in 1965 thanking
him for his work.
So, my original dissertation
was written in 1992,
and my research really
revolved on Stetson's life
up until this time, the 1960s.
But, Stetson's life
continued to revolve
around cultural advocacy.
And you know, he lived
another 50 years,
so it's a very full life.
During the 1970s and 80s,
this was when I knew Stetson,
he was working with
the Seminole Tribe
on traditional cultural issues.
This is him with Jim
Billy who's still the,
again, the tribal head.
He also worked with Alan
Lomax on several projects,
and reacquainted with
him in his later years.
This is from 1999, I think
that's when Alan actually came
up to be a living legend.
In his later years, they,
you know, connected again,
and up until Lomax's death
they were fast friends.
He also caught up with Ramblin'
Jack Elliot, and here they are
at Pete Seeger's
90th birthday party
in Madison Square
Garden backstage.
And they became, of
course, great friends again.
And he worked with Arlo Guthrie
to get Woody's unpublished
songs published.
Now, before I retired and moved
back to Florida, this picture's
from 2009, I began
working with Stetson
and the Stetson Kennedy
Foundation on several issues.
And this is one of my favorite
photos, it's of course,
Ramblin' Jack Elliot,
Arlo Guthrie,
and Stetson at a festival
that we held to raise money
to open a Writers
Residency at Beluthahatchee.
Stetson was also great
friends with MaVynee Betsch.
Has anybody heard of MaVynee
Betsch, the Beach Lady?
Yeah, she was a force
of nature, and she
and Stetson were
fast, fast friends.
MaVynee Betsch is the
great-granddaughter
of Abraham Lincoln Lewis,
who was the very first Black
millionaire from Jacksonville.
He had the African-American
life insurance company.
And back then, even the
ocean was segregated, and so,
Abraham Lincoln Lewis
bought 200 acres
on Amelia Island,
which is my home now.
And he started American Beach
which was advertised as the,
really the first
African-American resort
and vacation community
in Florida.
And MaVynee was an opera singer
at one time, she left that
and came down back
to American Beach.
When I met her -- I met
her a couple of times.
She had dreadlocks that
were like, seven feet long,
literally, a dreadlock that
went down to her ankles,
and she's got it piled here.
She was doing advocacy
work for --
she got a dune system on the
National Historic Register,
the largest dune system
in Florida called Nana.
And she was just
an amazing woman,
and go any of you
know Jeanetta Cole?
>> Yeah.
>> Peggy Bulger: Okay.
Well, when I was
getting ready --
so, I knew MaVynee and I knew
Jeanetta, because I'd worked
with Jeanetta when she was the
president of Spellman College.
And then, she became
the director
of the Smithsonian's
Museum of African Art.
And so, we were having
lunch, and I said, well,
I'm going to be retiring,
you know, soon.
And she says, "Oh, are you
going to stay up here?"
And I said, well, no,
I'm moving to Florida.
And she says, "Oh, Florida,
where are you moving to?"
And I said, well,
it's a little island,
you probably never heard of it.
And she says, "What island?"
And I said, Amelia Island.
She put down her
fork, and she says,
"My great-grandfather Abraham
Lincoln Lewis founded American
Beach, and MaVynee is my sister.
>> Oh!
>> Peggy Bulger: And I could
see the family resemblance,
there's like the
yen and the yang.
I mean, Jeanetta always
perfectly coiffed, yeah,
but anyway, it was just great.
So, these two women
forceful in their own areas,
and still have a connection
with American Beach.
So, Stetson of course,
worked with MaVynee
on several environmental issues.
And in his last decade, Stetson
was featured in several exhibits
on the Klan, and on
Florida's, I guess,
Civil Rights history
and labor history.
And he worked with the NAACP,
the Center for Democratic
Renewal,
the Southern Regional
Counsel, Klan Watch,
and the Southern
Poverty Law Center.
He was a consultant, and
also donated many objects
to museums and archives.
And I believe that this
Klan robe he donated
to the new African American
Museum here on the mall.
Beluthahatchee was
dedicated a literary landmark
for the second time in 2014, and
this time for Stetson's writing.
And these are just photos
of Stetson at Beluthahatchee
in his last years, and he
continued to be active.
This is Beluthahatchee Lake,
and he has a statue
of blue heron there.
He had a pet blue heron
he loved for many years.
At the age of 90, Stetson
married for the seventh time.
On November 24, 2006
to Sandra Parks,
who is an activist
from St. Augustine.
And then, they continued
to fight for civil rights,
labor struggles, and
environmental conservation.
And these are just the last
photos I have of Stetson.
This is in D.C. of
course, at a demonstration,
at an anti-Klan demonstration.
Also, back in Florida, he was
protesting public supermarkets,
because they wouldn't support a
once cent increase in the price
of tomatoes, so tomato pickers
could get health insurance.
So, he was very active
in helping them.
I love this, out with his
walker, and has a sign, yes!
And this is with NAACP workers.
This tree Stetson saved from
developers, they were going
to tear it down for development,
and it's now a Heritage tree.
And then, in 2005,
Stetson was inducted
to the Florida Artists
Hall of Fame.
And here he is with the --
our governor at the
time was Jeb Bush.
And this is him with
Lawton Childs,
the Progressive politician
from Florida,
had that same dedication.
And of course, he
was a speech --
featured speaker here at the
Library of Congress in 2005,
and that's all videotaped.
And as I was talking to somebody
before, most of his papers are
at the PK Yonge collection
at the University of Florida.
And they're also at the
Schaumburg Collection
in New York, and the Georgia
State University Labor archives.
and of course, Florida Archives
from the WPA collections
is up online here.
And if you haven't gotten
in to it, I recommend it.
August 27,2011, Stetson
Kennedy died.
It was just before
his 95th birthday,
and there was a huge celebration
in honor of his life.
And this is of course,
Beluthahatchee Lake,
and his daughter is spreading
his ashes on the lake.
And, although it was sad,
I'm kind of glad Stetson
has not been alive
for the past several
years in terms
of what's happening
with our country.
And I just have to --
I have to put that in,
but I won't get political.
And that's it.
[ Applause ]
I could probably
take a few questions,
if anybody's got any questions?
Yes?
>> Thank you so much, Peggy.
What an incredible life, and
can't wait to read your book.
My question is, what
started this young man
from a privileged background?
What got him thinking against
the grain, and in particular,
perhaps going into folk lore.
I mean, not only is there the
world view, but I'm astonished
at this young kid going out
and doing serious field work.
So, that's actually a
couple different questions
that come up [inaudible].
>> Peggy Bugler" Yeah.
Well, there were two things
that he mentions to me over
and over again in the
interviews I did with him.
One was that they had a Black
maid when he was growing up.
And he had -- when he
was a very young boy,
he had seen her being
beat up by a,
I think it was a
trolley car operator,
because she didn't
have the fare,
and he was just horrified
as a young boy.
But, I think what really started
him was that he had to go
into these neighborhoods
to get the dollar a week.
And he would hear
stories, first of all,
about why they don't
have the dollar.
But, also stories that would
just evolve from there,
both Black and White,
and realize that --
you know, that got him totally
out of his bailiwick into,
you know, the kind of poverty
that was just all around,
but nobody was recognizing it.
And then, just because
he started realizing
that he was hearing words
he'd never heard of before.
And he would make notes of them,
and that just started
then jokes.
He would, you know,
do jokes, and so,
that was really the
start of his education.
He would be like 15 years old
when he really kind
of, got into it.
And then, of course, when
he went away to college,
then the rest was history.
Yeah. Yeah?
>> What was the callous theme
to actually go undercover?
Was there an incident, or
was it just [inaudible]?
>> Peggy Bulger: What's that?
>> Was it one incident
that caused him to do --
it was a very profound act
to go undercover like that?
>> Peggy Bulger: Well, his
uncle was named John Perkins,
he was dead at the time, and
his uncle was a Klan member
when he was alive.
And so, Stetson, you know,
throughout his life
was really dedicated
to civil rights issues.
And he couldn't go in the army,
and I think he felt very bad
about not being able to -- well,
this -- wait, let me go back.
Like I said, he was
really trying to figure
out what is the answer?
It wasn't like democracy
was, you know,
totally had a lock on it.
He was looking at Communism,
he was looking -- some --
how can we alleviate
the poverty?
Because in Florida at the time,
and living through
The Depression.
And then when he went down
to Key West, you know,
and he saw that, you know,
people are resilient.
He decided that the hate
groups were Fascists.
And Fascism was the thing
that we really have to fight.
And so, you can fight
the Nazis in Germany,
or you can fight them here.
And that's what he decided,
especially since, you know,
the governor of Georgia
was a member.
Most of the policemen
were members, and so,
the people in power were
hiding under the hoods,
but they were Fascists.
And so, that's what
made him do it.
>> I was curious about
how his family reconciled
his difference?
Did he maintain a good
relationship with parents
and siblings, or were they just
like, "You are too out there?"
>> Peggy Bulger: No.
Over the years -- at the
very end of his life,
he had a fairly okay
relationship
with his younger sister.
But, his parents they -- he
could never keep his mouth shut.
You know, if -- you know how
-- I don't know about you,
but when I go to a family,
you know, Thanksgiving,
I just kind of don't talk
about religion and politics.
Just don't talk about it, you
know, because it is, you know,
you're in a family where --
he was just so out there.
And they were so
embarrassed by him,
because they were,
you know, society.
They were southern
society, yeah.
>> Not to take anything at
all away from this great man,
but it -- there have been
suggestions in recent years
that to some extent, he may have
embellished the degree to --
>> Peggy Bulger: You're talking
about Steven Dubner
Freakanomics, yeah.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yeah. That was the
saddest -- that was a sad day.
Here's Stetson who's in his
90s, who's been working all
of his life for -- okay, in my
dissertation, Steven Dubner,
who's one of the
coauthors of Freakanomics.
They -- in their original book
they did one of the chapters
on why is the Klu Klux Klan
like an insurance company
or something like that?
Anyway, they had come down
and interviewed Stetson,
and Stetson never
asked them for a dime.
They used his story
to make, you know,
a kazillion dollars
on Freakanomics.
Anyway, after the book came out,
there is an author if Florida,
Ben Green, and who's
a historian,
who has a long-standing
-- I wouldn't say feud.
But, a long-standing
animosity with Stetson.
And he contacted
them and said, "Oh,
you know Stetson
didn't do all that.
He -- " well, and in
fact, he was very --
almost to the point
of libeling Stetson.
So, I get a call from Dubner,
and he wanted my dissertations,
so he could read
what I had written.
So, I gave it -- you know, I
told him where he could get it.
And I -- and he asked me
about it, and I said, no,
in my dissertation even --
and you know, and Stetson,
when he was talking to
me, he said, "You know,
I was undercover with
another man who never wanted
to be -- he was smart.
He never wanted to
be identified, so,
be didn't want anything,
no mention of him at all."
But, I said, he -- we're
calling him, you know, John Doe.
But, there was another
man who was also working
with Stetson and
doing this work.
But, somehow that got blown
complete -- and here's my own --
my own theory is that, the
authors of Freakanomics wanted
to sell more books, so
they wrote this article
in the New York Times
Magazine called Hoodwinked.
In which they, you
know, took everything
that Ben Green had said,
and you know, said, "Oh",
you know, "He's made this up."
Well, they used my
dissertation as a citation.
And I was furious, so I wrote
to the New York Times Magazine,
and do did Studs Terkel.
And so, I'm very
happy that my letter,
and Studs Terkel's letter
are right there together.
But, I said, where
is the smoking gun?
You know, Dubner --
he admitted to me,
never read my dissertation,
all he did was look
at the one citation.
And he's writing like he
knows what he's talking about,
he doesn't.
And first of all, if he had
gone down and done all this work
with Stetson, shouldn't he
had found that out right away?
I mean, it was no big secret.
And the way that Stetson writes,
if you can get a copy of I Rode
with the Klu Klux Klan, which is
his book, you know, the expose.
It reads like a Mickey
Spillane novel, it's --
you know, and it was like
Stetson wanted his audience
to be the people who were under
the hoods who were thinking
about getting under the hoods.
He wasn't writing for
an academic audience.
the history books,
he was writing something that
would capture their imagination,
and make them realize,
this is not the way to go.
You know, this is -- and
how crazy this is, you know?
This is -- so, it was
like a big brouhaha.
And unfortunately, it about
killed Stetson, I mean,
he was so upset, because,
you know, he just didn't want
to have to go to court
and everything like that.
But, it kind of --
that's what it was.
And I do -- in the book,
I get into that, yeah.
>> Okay, one more question,
we're going to do one
question, we're [inaudible].
>> Peggy Bulger: Okay.
No? Oh.
>> I've heard Stetson
tell the story of going
down in Key West
a number of times,
and he always made it very
clear, the he shipped a crate
of books ahead of him, so that
it got there before he did,
so he continued his studies.
So, the question I have is ,
do you know why he did drop
of school, and do that?
>> Peggy Bulger: Yeah, he
ran out of money, mm-hmm.
It was the Depression,
and his family wasn't --
you know, because he
was so radicalized,
they weren't going
to support him.
He had one aunt who would send
him five-dollars a month back
in Key West.
And back in that time that
was enough to survive on --
with his WPA job, or, you
know, racking seaweed.
Yeah. That -- good point.
Yeah.
>> I want to thank Peggy Bulger
for a wonderful talk,
and for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Peggy Bulger: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> She'll be signing
books in the foyer,
and there's also a small
exhibit over on the side on some
of the material on
Stetson Kennedy
from the American
Folklife Center.
And thank you so
much for coming.
And please come back tomorrow,
tomorrow we have another event
called the American Folklife
Centers Archive Challenge.
Where we have a group
of wonderful musicians
who have taken material
from our collection,
and are going to
be performing it.
So, here tomorrow at noon.
Please come back and
join us then, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov